hallo herzlich willkommen in sellis Welt
ihr wisst wir sind Cheesecake Liebhaber
die ganze Firma liebt
Cheesecake ja und deswegen gibt's heute
einen Oreo San Sebastian
[Musik]
Cheesecake San Sebastian Cheesecake den
habe ich ja schon auf meinem Kanal das
Original der San Sebastian Cheesecake
ist aber so dass er eigentlich dieser
burned Cheesecake ist also der aus dem
Baskenland der außen verbrannt ist und
innen sehr cremig war wahrscheinlich
damals einfach ein Unfall hat sich so
durchgesetzt und jetzt ist es eine
Delikatesse jedenfalls mache ich es hier
jetzt im Rezept so dass ich den nicht
ganz außen anbrennen lasse weil ich weiß
viele mögen es viele nicht heute machen
wir so bisschen die abgeschwächtere
Version davon packen noch Oreos mit rein
Murat hat sich das Rezept gewünscht ich
gebst so Murat hat sich gewünscht
deswegen machen was also ich zeige euch
mal die Zutaten und die sollten dieses
Mal zimmerwarm sein also Frischkäse und
Sahne gerne etwas früher aus dem
Kühlschrank rausholen dafür verwende ich
640 g Frischkäse in Doppelrahmstufe 180
g Zucker etwas Salz Vanilleextrakt 25 g
Mehl 3 Eier 320 g Sahne und 100 g Oreo
Kekse jetzt geht's ganz einfach ihr
nimmt den Frischkäse packt den in eine
große Rührschüssel Zucker und Salz
kommen dazu und ihr benutzt kein
handrühgerät sondern am Anfang erstmal
nur einen Teigschaber das ganze schön
verrühren der frisch Käse wird so ein
bisschen flüssiger und dann könnt ihr
nach und nach Vanilleextrakt und Mehl
dazu geben nach und nach die Eier dazu
rühren gern auch auf einen Schneebesen
jetzt umschwenken und die Sahne ganz
langsam und behutsam einrühren bis eine
klümpchenfreie Masse
entsteht dann habe ich jetzt hier meinen
springfahbudden 20 cm eine
Dauerbackfolie und ein Tortenring ist
jetzt auch wichtig drauf zu achten dass
ihr einen spring vom Boden nehmt oder
das ganze mit Backpapier einschlagt denn
die Masse ist sehr flüssig die wird
sonst wirklich Auslaufen ich hatte euch
auch im anderen s Sebastian Cheesecake
Video gezeigt dass ihr auch zwei
Tortenringe nehmen könnt und die so ein
bisschen übereinander geht mit
Backpapier dazwischen könnt ihr auch
gerne machen Hauptsache das hier ist
jetzt auch fest genug es kann trotzdem
sein dass ein bisschen was ausläuft denn
es ist einfach wie Wasser richtig
richtig flüssig aber prst das jetzt hier
einfach richtig rein da kommt die Masse
rein und dann zerkleinere ich noch die
Oreos das ma ich jetzt aber vorher denn
der Kuchen sollte dann direkt in den
Ofen in den heißen damit die Masse
gleich anfängt zu stocken und es dauert
schon bisschen bis da jetzt backt danach
neimmt ihr ihn raus und lasst den
wirklich komplett abkühlen und dann
kommt er noch in den
[Musik]
Kühlschrank
jetzt ist der Kuchen abgequüt ich habe
ih gerade aus dem Kühlschrank
rausgenommen und ihr könnt ihn jetzt im
Prinzip direkt aus der Form auslösen und
auf eine Tortenplatte
[Musik]
setzen ganz wichtig dass er schön kalt
ist ansonsten könnt ih nämlich wirklich
gar nicht schneiden auch nicht rauslösen
weil er so cremig
ist
[Musik]
wunderschön und jetzt nehme ich mir noch
etwas Sahne so ungefähr 200 g geb
Vanilleextrakt dazu und sahapad und
schlag die Sahne
steif und dann nimmt ihr die Sahnecreme
und die kommt jetzt hier drauf ich mein
der würd jetzt so schon perfekt
schmecken aber mit so einer locker
leichten Sahnecreme ist wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen besser probieren wir
jetzt
gleich ich habe die auch extra so ein
bisschen ihr seht die schon die so
bisschen
cremig einfach schön cremig und wenn ihr
wollt nehmt euch noch ein paar Oreo
Kekse und zerbröselt sie einfach
drüber
[Musik]
Wahnsinn und jetzt wie üblich bei dem
sasti Cheesecake
Zack und jetzt gucken wir wie cremig er
ist ne
ult schade dass du das jetzt nicht
probieren kannst dass du lieber mit Mura
mit günny und Josh gon in der Werkstatt
abhängst und jetzt den leckeren Oreo
Cheesecake nicht probieren kannst den
ich für dich gebacken
hab
h so ein
Jammer
m
mhm wow ich will euch echt nicht
zuschmatzen aber der ist richtig gut vor
allem eiskalt aus dem
Kühlschrank der perfekte Cheesecake also
probiert ihn gerne mal aus ich finde
auch die Größe wirklich gut weil so ein
20 cm Kuchen ich meine der ist schon
mächtig muss man sagen ich könnte es
jetzt einfach nicht da noch irgendwie
Schokosoße oder so drauf ich finde die
Sahne die lockert den voll auf Oreo
Kekse passen er ist auch nicht zu süß
ist wirklich so einfach perfekt man kann
sogar noch wenn man will so ein paar
johannisbären dazu legen wenn man eine
fruchtkomponente will aber ich finde der
Kuchen in sich passt der Cheesecake ist
cremig die Sahne ist nicht süß aber
trotzdem locker und vanillig und es
passt einfach alles perfekt probiert
also gerne aus das Rezept findet ihr wie
immer in meiner App oder auf
sellis-blog.de viel Spaß dabei und bis
zum nächsten Mal und schreibt mir ganz
gerne welche Rezepte ihr euch als
nächstes
wünscht hey Leute ich bin Murat und das
ist mein Kumpel günny wir haben
wahrscheinlich momentan die teuerste und
spektakulärste handwerkersendung im
deutschen Fernsehen geht jetzt direkt in
die AD Mediathek gibt dort ein Murat
dreht am Rad und seht uns beim
Handwerken wie wir unglaubliche Dinge
machen sag do auch was mir fehlen die
Worte ja mir
auch ach du scheiße das Ding kriegen wir
wahrscheinlich nie mehr wieder zum
Laufen warte waret
doch mach du mach du mach du ah die
Tagesschausprecher die ist aber hässlich
WTE ich will einmal dass meine Mama
anruft mich abholt
baby
baby hallo liebe baumarktkunden oh mein
Gott kannst ein deine Hände einfach nur
drin lassen ich einfach
nur was hab den ihr
gemacht Vollgas
[Musik]
Vollgas
ah